was bad well what happened
marlon wayans is an actor comedian
writer and producer but you might know
him as seymour stewart
smell like bologna or how about luke dog
we
maybe you've seen him share some screen
time with his famous family on the
wayans brothers
and of course he starred in some of the
biggest comedy classics out there like
in living color scary movie naked and
this fan favorite do you know this isn't
going to work
oh my gosh iconic and you hear that song
you know where that song is from let's
welcome marlon wayans to las vegas now
we are so honored to have you on
thank you for having me i like that
theme song you know when i go to brazil
and they play that thing that song it's
so big in brazil they don't call it it's
called bronchitis that's what they call
white chicks in
brazil they literally will stop the club
and sing to me
like the whole club it's so dope okay so
when you do hear that song though
wherever you are in the world does it
bring back good memories are you sick of
it what happens in your mind what i
smile with like
one of the best
worst experiences of my life i've never
worked so hard in my life you know it
don't take me it took me seven hours of
makeup to to be a whiteboard it don't
take me that long to be a black man i
wake up and i am him
so that was a grueling process wearing
those little feet the little heels y'all
be wearing y'all have to wear heels you
know we wouldn't think about the
airforce today
i got on air forces today okay
i feel you
put them up
exactly exactly no what has been we saw
a little montage of some of the
characters you played what has been the
fate your favorite character so far your
most memorable one besides white chicks
i don't know man so many like um it's
funny that in white chicks
we played these two cuban guys the
bodega owners and
yeah yeah
like all that he's not even speaking
like real spanish and my brother has to
interpret it so i would do something
physical like
those two guys because that took extreme
trust yes for me to go there and trust
him to interpret wow but that but that's
the beauty of being family right you
guys have grown up together you guys
know each other like nobody else so
let's talk about family by the way i
grew up with cara and kyla we both we
all went to a squarely demonstrator
together did you yes
i've been to your family parties i've
yes beautiful talented fans oh i just
had a car i had a baby i know i know i
know i know i love following our lives i
haven't seen you another one is barbecue
i know well i need to get an invite
well come on through
some dresses in the air force i got you
i got you i got you so let's talk about
the wayne's family what was it like
growing up in that household
crazy i mean
we
it was a house full of jokes like we
didn't have many
tears in our household
but when they came through
they always were like turned into
laughter we've always laughed at the
worst circumstance about everyday
circumstance was terrible but we always
found what's funny and that's always
been our escape so whenever something
tragic happens to us usually the
funniest thing comes out of that
treasure
well is that something we can we can see
on stage at the end resort this weekend
oh yeah oh yeah
i would talk about it man um you know
it's beautiful that you know at the end
resort i got a brand new set
and i was there last year and it was a
lot of fun and great crowds um it's hard
as hell in vegas somehow y'all still
smile so it's a great set and it's
really funny and you know it's not
enough picking on the audience it's all
about me joke's on me so you got to come
in there and have a good time okay and
you're taking it off the strip we're in
henderson getting the local crowd we
like that you're kind of combining
everybody what do you like to do when
you're in the if people if the people in
vegas love me then they'll travel 20
minutes to come see me that's if y'all
love me if i am working 20 minute drive
then what the hell did i do all this
work for you
exactly exactly no i completely agree i
completely agree is that what i'll let
you do yeah what do you like to do over
here
oh see the
let's see the sides i'll trip club
basically strip clips
a lot of education there
i learned a lot about bbl's and things
of that nature oh dear yes and a lot of
education on stage at em resort on
saturday for your show you know just
kind of tell everybody why they should
come see it and what they can expect
from you
because i'm i'm funny i've been doing
this for i've been doing funny since i
was born yeah you're guaranteed to laugh
you're not going to have a a more fun
time anywhere else in vegas um or in
nevada so come on out and then the m has
some great food and some you know it's a
great vibe so i'm gonna be chilling at
the m resort all weekend so come on
let's see marlin marlon i gotta tell you
if you're gonna be in henderson with the
locals and the tourists you gotta say
nevada not nevada
you gotta say nevada what's wrong in the
bottom
pronouncing them yeah i want to say it
like that you got to say nevada
i'm just trying to you know just in case
i'm just trying not to get you jumped on
stage by the locals
15 strands of weed and we gonna have
that we ain't inviting nobody
marlon i am gonna tell cara and kylo on
you okay thank you so much for joining
us you can see marlon
at the end resort spot casino tomorrow
at 8pm doors open at 7. to buy tickets
just go to
ticketmaster.com thank you marlene